[Music]
john i i've got an article it's fresh
it's like those uh it's like the hot now
sign at krispy kreme
all right this is like this is hot wall
street journal so fresh and so clean
clean let's do it okay
um and here's the headline and and you
have an interesting perspective on this
yeah because of your higher ed
background yes so i'm really fascinated
okay
all right al lord here's the headline al
lord
profited when college tuition rose he is
paying for it
al lord is the former chief executive
student loan giant
sally may and he's got to complain about
higher
higher education this is where it gets
rich the irony is so deep right here you
might need a life jacket
exactly the price of college is too high
he says
paying for his grandchildren's education
in recent years he said
left him appalled at the tuition bills
that land on his desk
every semester this is a direct quote
boy
am i sure glad we saved for my grandkids
if the average income is forty thousand
or fifty thousand or sixty thousand
i just don't know how you do it for the
record al he's still out of touch
the median family income in the united
states right now is seventy eight
thousand five hundred dollars so just a
quick snapshot all right but that's the
median but there's also a median
tons of people outside that's right a
lot of people in that range he's talking
about yeah 40 000 or lower right
and he's going how do they afford it
well the news is al they can't they
don't but you
set up a system where they feel like
they might be able to
the irony john uh so that goes on in
this article where he basically comes
out and says
i knew what was going on um he was like
look
here's what happened i was a partner in
the government and
congress gave sally may an unbelievable
return they encouraged banks
to finance all these loans and then it
turned into this massive
massive company where the stock holdings
were worth 300 million
dollars and he says in this article
there's no question in my mind
i knew what was going on he knew that
they were making it easier and easier
and easier for people to go into debt
he's admitting this um so there you go
um when i read this i was like you have
got to be kidding me
coming out saying yeah it's too much
yeah but they allowed it
see because higher ed's basically said
all right let's just keep jacking up
tuition
because we're giving people vehicle to
do it and so i want to ask you this i've
been talking about this
malcolm gladwell's been big on this
issue you got harvard i think has a 40
billion
endowment columbia i think
top 10 endowments in the country their
staff
and even um some of their leading
educators
in administration have asked can we use
some of the endowment
to help pay for the graduate degrees and
they're not doing it i just want to know
what are your thoughts here how do we
not
feel like this is about big business and
not about education
yeah i've heard the phrase with some of
the schools um that they
are hedge funds with uh a student
component to them right
that they're just giant hedge fund
companies a couple of things
haven't been inside it's easy to think
of an endowment as just a giant savings
account
much of endowment funds are in are tied
up in
a donor gives this much money and wants
it paid out to this
type of thing over so it has strings
attached
tons of strings right so when i think of
an endowment i just think of a savings
account in my
and it's not how those always work now
you can get creative and find new ways
etc
i think at the end of the day you've got
a group of schools with massive
endowments
and thousands of schools that do not
have that and so to lump everybody in
that pilot
is tough so let's get away from the
endowment conversation let's just talk
about this has been a steady rise in
tuition
it's just been going going going going
going and
here's the guy that led sally maine he's
going it's out of control yeah it's too
much
what what i mean
i was part of a think tank that we dug
into this thing the challenge here is
it's a strange strange universe um you
can actually create a
a college tuition model that has no no
loans
no uh no scholarships
that here's just what it costs to come
here and people came back
it's the jcpenney model you know what
we're not doing any more sales we're not
we're just gonna it cost seven dollars
get a shirt come get a shirt and jc
penney
almost went away right people want this
idea that
i am gonna pay more but get a
scholarship and do with this and get it
it's just a game that's gotten out of
control on everybody and
somebody outside that system is going to
come up and disrupt the whole thing
because it can't work
no and colleges i've known this
for years again i've sat with people the
clocks tick have wept
they've like we know we've got to stop
doing this to kids and
they just can't seem to turn the nozzle
and um
unfortunately when you can't turn the
nozzles on your own house somebody will
come and do it for you
and you can talk to the blockbusters of
the world you i mean it happens yeah
codex of the world
and there's a storm brewing it's coming
both ways it's been brewing and brewing
and brewing
it's hard not to think that higher ed
cares more about their fortunes than
your future that's what i say it's hard
man
and uh it's tough stuff so very
interesting stuff there it's uh
it i'll tell you this ramsay solutions
we're going to get in this we're going
to be disrupting this stuff i mean
because here's the deal people are going
to get to the point where they're going
look i need to get qualified
and there's lots of ways to get
qualified well what you're starting to
see happen
is quiet proposals like the american
counseling association
quietly says why don't like why don't we
just
create our own program right um
when uh or and i just picked them out of
the year
when ge finally just says you know what
we're going to train you for 18 months
you can work for us
oh it's going to start happening it's
going to start chipping off so google's
already doing it so google announced a
major initiative last year okay where
they've got six-month training programs
in several key areas yeah
mostly technology-based but they're like
it's like a hiring farm system like the
major lakes yeah and they've got a farm
so can i ask you you're training people
as a citizen so i'm a i'm a lifelong
educator so my bias is there
i always want our citizens to know about
history
and i saw that thing the other day that
this many middle schoolers and high
schoolers
have no concept of nazi german they
don't know what that story is right
that's tragic so you you've got history
you've got
basic science we've got folks like we
talked about the code vaccine earlier
folks who we don't even have basic
science literacy across the board so we
can't even say
is this is that there's science there's
there's
math there's just general quote unquote
knowledge
my fear about having some of these
companies break off and say you know
what i'm gonna do an 18 month training
program come work for me
is you lose a collective knowledge on
the other side of it is
i we can't charge a hundred thousand
dollars for we can't it's impossible i
think you're making
it good how do you find that balance
well so so because i'm pretty vocal on
this stuff yeah and i've had some
educators i've had some educators come
in and go what is your why do you hate
higher education i go number one i don't
yeah i respect the liberal arts
but what i'm saying is is there's more
to the college experience
than just your liberal arts well yeah
and so you're gonna have to get trained
you guys are gonna have to step your
game up in training
people to be able to move into the
workforce and adapt it to go work
i love the focus on liberal arts and i
would say this that i i probably am
going to freak you out on this but i i'm
for a basic
level yeah um of history i think we need
to be teaching that better
yeah in the in the in the elementary
middle school and high school
but once you get to the college age
unless you want to go into history
i could be like hey you know look we
we've got to make higher education
about preparing people for their future
so to me
i go i love you know this i love a
custom i love some customization
meaning a kid comes in and goes look i
want to go into this and we go hey we
think this would be good
and i'm for some core stuff at college
but i'm not as concerned about it i'm
more concerned about what you're talking
about
why is this true because of our current
education system
in k through 12. yeah i remember stuff
from history
from k through 12. i remember stuff
about science not a whole lot because i
don't like science
and but i'm not good at science and
that's what i teach and that's where i
think a lot of the higher ed problems
outside of the pricing issue which is a
whole other thing
and you start rolling downhill and start
pulling that thread and it comes all the
way back to
test space and kindergarten middle
school we
so the bottom line is it's got to be
more more relevant
and it's got to be easier for people to